gnarrk and now it's time for how to be a
pirate
coming from dead stars pom pom gratings
momiji's black dog bills some call me
but only when the drunkest my real name
is howard here's a teacher how to be a
pilot today we're going to be looking at
swords that is good for a pilot to have
a soul especially one made of such fine
material Laura the finest steel
toys-r-us can bite sure it's not made
not gonna find this stuff and you don't
really want to wiggle it back and forth
cuz you didn't yeah you don't want to do
that recipes I sword nonetheless isn't a
right Nancy blew me a blowhard
I'm not kidding either whenever somebody
says there she blows they all look in
her direction and they're not looking
for Moby Dick Soren is to always hold it
by the handle yeah I have no idea how
many people make the mistake of holding
it by the wrong in that's how captain
what what's his hand you know by holding
it the wrong way well actually just your
my small cut on the finger buddy cut off
its hand just to be sure the other
important thing to remember about just
sorry bees don't use it as a toothpick
when pirates ooh the sword making
company just because of that and he won
he got the same lawyer that told
McDonald's that their coffee was hot
that's why all sorts say I'm the very
bottom of the handle caution shrimp this
one doesn't happen because well yeah
another important thing to remember
about your sword is where test dick
what sex pirate had the misfortune of
sticking the sword down his trousers
this was not smart he pulled out his
sword at the wrong angle and let's just
say he's no longer called Long John
Silver he's now called shorten penis
iron the same thing happened a peg leg
Johnson who not only has a peg leg but
also a pig Johnson he was to say he does
give new meaning to the term count would
ya cat would bite him you probably also
get termites with herpes is that not
right mister I don't don't bother me
what yeah yeah go water the man is so
think he thought Davy Jones's Locker was
where a member of the monkeys kept his
gym clothes but back to swords using
your sword in battle is very very
important in fact is very important to
chop off as many body parts as possible
ie once cut off a man's arm using this
though of course he was already dead and
it took several hours but of course says
the ancient Zen philosophy Miz said you
only have a sword so you hope never to
use it that's why we have done this will
not work very well against the gun far
as the old saying goes he who lives by
the sword dies by the sword unless their
prison has a gun in which case you will
die by a gun in fact I'm sorry you
should probably get yourself a gun it's
like a sword it can kill a guy because
whenever somebody sneezes in heaven it's
like dad always says blood fear joke
bless they say that five out of the
seven seas were made by blood beer joke
from the tears of the women he turned
down for a second beer joke got messed
up so badly that's his own beer had to
give him a refund blood beer Joe he may
not be done oh wait yes tune in next
time he may tease for hello to be a
pilot see you soon
this war is how to be a pirate the
greatest show that of Earth yummy mateys
it's true that stories about blood beer
joking around quite quickly so if you
heard some stories about blood beer Joe
that displays his awesomeness send it to
this address a pirate that awesome
deserve so many comparisons submit it
now and maybe you'll be in the next
episode
but tournament quick lands because I
want them quick